a plug for the PA History Society put
your hands up if you've ever gone to the
PA History Society website dick Hall has
not done that yet
pa H x.org PA h xorg just click on that
and a whole world of PA history will
open before you there's several of us
now who are old enough to be trustees of
this organization Tom Pym is one Ruth
ball wig is another I am another and
it's another and so we are having a
great old time doing a lot of what we
just did today looking back at the early
days but we would like your
contributions and suggestions we want it
we there you'll see biographies on this
website we want BIOS from you early
people so we want to hear from you
that's my first plug the second thing
the in terms of a sense of today I'm
reminded of how I think you have as a
piays an ideal profession you have in
spite of all the chaos and confusion
as an bliss says to no one is to love
one that was one of her great that's
about what's a PA to know one is to love
with in spite of the confusion that was
discussed and the continual evolution
from one rule to another you still have
I think the most vibrant power-packed
two years of education and therefore
future of any health profession I know
it is it's just extraordinary and when
you look at those magazine surveys that
Pat talked about earlier today
Forbes magazine Money Magazine pas are
behind IT only as the most popular
profession the first physician
subspecialty on the list is about
seventeenth and one or twenty one and
another who wants to go to school for
four years and residency for four and
run up all that debt and to get take two
K take care of patients when you can do
that if you really want to be clinicians
which is what you want to do ninety
seven percent of graduates are doing
clinical medicine I just think you owe
yourselves a great round of applause for
that I think that's fantastic then the
final thing I'll say that organization
that's so impressive is the fact that
although there has been some degree
creep in this profession a phrase that
Tom Pym has educated me about and we
started out with certificates it's all
about what you can do it's not a matter
of what your degree is and and bliss has
written so much about nursing's mistakes
if forty years ago to discard the
diploma nerves in favor of credentials
at least you stopped and settle on the
master's degree which i think is a very
appropriate degree for the level of
skill that you have there was an Atlanta
summit two years ago that I was
fortunate to be part of and which PA
leaders talked about what should be the
terminal degree for our profession and
we heard the people from physical
therapy talk about their his
during the last eight years they've gone
from one program in the country that
grants a doctorate in PT to every
program in the country
so all PT people coming out physical
therapists are doctors of PT the same
thing in occupational therapy the same
thing in pharmacy we're about to see
nursing practice with this Doctor of
Nursing degree
come down the highway we none of us know
what that means but I think you've been
very very smart to say this is who we
are this is what we're going to do
that's what the summit decided that
weekend that's what the double-a PA Paea
went along with and validated I think
that from an organizational point of
view was a brilliant move on your part
and I congratulate you for that so I'm
gonna just stand here to make sure it
doesn't go on too long I'm not as
worried about Blair actually I'm still
getting time back from Ann so I kind of
live in a different world now in terms
of policy and big trends and I thought I
would share in sort of a 30,000 foot
views seven mega trends though I think
you might want to be one is the quality
revolution starting with the IOM report
and that's now front and center or no
one's saying no America's the best and
second is transparency in the Internet
so when the cover of the Boston Globe
and whatever are the adjusted cardiac
mortality scores for every hospital in
Boston that would been unthinkable eight
years ago a third is the rise of the
baby boomers and consumers of care going
from passive consumers whatever the
person tells me I will accept - I know
more about the disease than you do and
I'm mad as hell and I'm not going to
take it anymore for is the the
reimbursement revolution so October 1
2008 is a watershed date when CMS
started to move from
a four-volume to pay for value pay for
volume to pay for value so they're now
27 never events that the National
Quality forum have identified that
should never occur in a hospital like
getting an acquired infection or a
patient fall and the incremental cost of
that extra stay you get paid zero which
is a good thing
that's just that's kind of that'll be a
tsunami this all helps you guys I would
argue another thing is H caps do you
know what an H cap is okay mandatory
patient satisfaction reporting Hospital
consumer attitude patient preference
survey so as a Medicare beneficiary now
I'm proud to say if I'd the hip
replacement that I had eight years ago
when I wasn't a Medicare beneficiary I
couldn't choose between sharp and
Scripps and Kaiser and UCSD and San
Diego about how people felt about their
experience now we can go on the internet
one place because every Medicare patient
fund discharge has to give you that
information so if you can improve the
patient experience you're going to drive
value very big megatrend CMS is a
completely different organization under
don berwick and who may not last much
longer
but don't think of it just as a payment
system has a center for innovation it's
doing amazing pilot work and Michael
talked about this earlier it's a source
of great new knowledge and ideas
sustainability and green is about to
become mainstream hospitals are driving
millions of dollars out of their cost
base by energy reduction toxic waste
reduction and again an area where you
could work what does that mean for you
do those trans mean for you I think
there's a new model of care called the
Triple Aim the Triple Aim and it's
populate think of a triangle population
health not individual patients through
the door the patient experience and
reducing cost per capita and the
mechanism for doing that
are called accountable healthcare
organizations H a CE OS which will be
new models new legal models of doctors
and hospitals pas can play a huge role
in this these a CE OS and they will
start to take over because we have two
ways of cutting costs out of the system
is usually the salami approach you know
cut every doctor by 10% or every
hospital by 15% or do something more
intelligent which is to give more like
Canada a defined amount of dollars to a
new organization which pas can play a
prominent role to do those three things
so I think those are really huge I would
avoid I would continue to avoid the
ideological debates were more polarized
than we've ever been in my lifetime and
so you guys are staying out of that
that's good thing second thing I would
say is get really involved in quality
improvement understand the methodology
and the research about quality
improvement I would have it in every
curriculum and every PA program in the
country I would know all about Institute
for Healthcare Improvement they give it
all away it's all free but it's a whole
different way of looking at problems
small sample size small tests of change
changes you go not randomized trials
over ten year period I would really
continue as you did last night
put the patient voice first put the
patient in the center of the circle and
if you can talk about what you do from
the standpoint of the patient
perspective you'll win and to many of
the other arguments get lost if you can
do research and cost reduction that
reduced cost per captive care that's a
win so I for example Mary would love to
see if you're not already doing it
that's my last point someone doing
you've been doing hospitalists at Yale
New Haven Hospital for X years well how
all other British Columbia question you
said one of the motivations versus
physicians Ruth what's that relative
cost and how does that go to the bottom
line because if you can start showing
the cost-effectiveness of PAS in these
different settings as
pose to physicians or other practice
models you'll get CEOs to want you know
become indispensable you'll change
policy in your states and you'll help
with playing major roles and accountable
care organizations so those are just
some thoughts that I had for you thanks